[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time to see then what is
making the headlines with the political
editors of the daily mirror and the son
pippa crira and harry cole who both join
us from the labour party conference in
brighton welcome to both of you plenty
to talk about so let's check out the
newspapers their front pages starting
with the metro britain gets back on
board their front page reads as
commuters begin choosing trains and
buses over their cars amid the long
queues at petrol stations
the eye writing about tonight's
developments that the army could be
called up to help tackle the fuel crisis
the financial times also running with
the fuel crisis story they say that the
health service could be at risk because
of a lack of fuel
the daily telegraph with a similar angle
saying that some petrol stations could
be reserved for key workers the times
also writing about key workers getting
priority two at the pumps
yorkshire post writes about a joint
statement between fuel companies and the
government urging people to buy
not to buy fuel in excess
the guardian front page has the comments
made by german election front runner
olaf schultz who says brexit is to blame
for the uk's fuel crisis
so let's get the initial thoughts then
of pippa and harry uh down at the labor
party conference in brighton uh more of
that to come but first of all um the
government uh finally deciding that it
will put the army on standby harry
assigned do you think that this is
really now being taken seriously or just
the optics of looking like they're doing
something
well i think if you're talking about
optics it hasn't been a great day for
the government we had george eustis the
environment secretary out this morning
saying there is no crisis there is no
shortage just a shortage of uh just a
shortage of fuel in the pumps and i
think anyone driving past a petrol
station in the last 72 hours will know
how sort of out of touch that looked
then he said there were no immediate
plans to send in the army and yet
tonight we know that the business
department has given a formal request to
the ministry of defense which has been
signed off by the defense secretary for
150 tanker drivers we're told
we need specialist training to be able
to use to use tankers and handle such
flammable liquids but they will be ready
uh to begin service perhaps as soon as
the end of the week
now the government will be hoping that
by then those that are going to go out
and choose to panic by will be smuggling
back at home with a full tank and things
will get back to normal if everything
just calms down but there's a big gap i
think tonight between the government's
hope and the government's rhetoric
and the reality that people are seeing
on the on the far courts yes and and all
of this amidst this idea that hgv
drivers from abroad can come in and fix
this problem you know the temporary visa
issue we heard about over the weekend um
but it's a very short period of time
they could come it may well be that they
can't even get accommodation for such a
short period of time up to christmas and
the suggestion from the eye that uh
these hgv drivers from abroad not
expected to arrive until at least the
end of october which by then hopefully
this will all have calmed down pippa
well that's right the government is
hoping of course that this all settles
down in the next few days because the
problem is not of course the lack of
fuel in the refineries or the storage
facilities it's a lack of fuel actually
in the pumps and the fact that people
have inevitably really haven't been told
not to panic by gone out and done
exactly that
um but once everyone's tanks are fuel a
fool and they realize that there isn't
going to be a longer term shortage then
hopefully the next few days the pumps
will be able to refill and and the
immediate crisis will be over but there
is obviously
ongoing
issues with not just supply of fuel but
obviously supply
goods to supermarkets and all sorts of
other things resulting from the driver
shortage
the problem is of course that if the
government is desperate to avoid these
supply issues manifesting themselves in
the run-up to christmas and causing big
problems then then they're going to
really have to get a bit of a move on
and as i suggest it's going to be
end of october before these drivers
start to arrive there's only 5 000 visas
being issued in the first instance the
suggestion that there's a shortage of
100 000 drivers so i can't see it being
resolved either very quickly or when the
new drivers come if they come
whether that's going to be enough to
plug some of the gaps
all sorts of blame being floated around
today and over the weekend harry blaming
the public for for panic buying blaming
the whistleblower who revealed that uh
one uh four court or one chain of four
courts had an hgv shortage and was
having to close a couple um of petrol
stations um but fundamentally do you
think this is this is acted as sort of
direct action from the consumer to raise
something which the government's been
told about for several months which is
this hgv driver shortage which which
hauliers have been have been banging on
about
absolutely i mean we've been running a
campaign i think since july in the sun
to get more uh british hgv licenses
available get more people training as
htv drivers this shouldn't have come as
a shock to the government it's been sort
of a slow motion to coin a phrase car
crash uh for them there has clearly been
a bit of a a bit of a uh a mess up i
think by the road haulers association by
the large uh haulers in this country who
have been desperately trying to pressure
behind the scenes the last six or so
months uh this idea to get the
government to soften their line on the
amount of visas that are given to
european drivers to come here there has
been a furious route going on for
several months behind the scenes and it
does feel to me a little bit like um
they were playing you know both sides
were slightly playing with fire in this
they pushed themselves to the brink
uh in their sort of you know they wanted
to put a little bit of pressure on the
government but no one wanted it to be
this full-scale panic but the genie is
out of the bottle now and it's up to the
ministers to try and calm things down
but you've got you know the environment
secretary saying don't panic literally
on television and postcovid i think you
know the british public have been told
lots of mixed messages over the last 18
months and i think you know
a government minister saying don't panic
everything's going to be fine isn't
quite what it used to be i'd say two
years ago so you know you're seeing a
sort of a reaping of what has been sown
over the last year or so of mixed
messages and confusion around the
pandemic and actually people don't quite
believe the government in a way that
they might have done before when they
say don't worry there's loads of fuel
carrying with your day people want to
take the law into their own hands yes i
mean even funeral directors suggesting
that funerals might have to be cancelled
because they can't get the fuel they
need for for hearses daily telegraph of
course reporting uh the the clamour to
get key workers to to the front of the
pumps is that likely to happen might
that be mandated certainly george eustis
tonight on um the sky showcase sky news
news show the great debate suggested
that that would be down to individual
companies and individual organizations
how that would work i have no idea
yeah and the suggestion from downing
street earlier was that that is not on
the cards for now but um but as we as we
also know you know things have changed
very quickly we were told as as recently
this morning that uh the army were only
going to be involved uh when it came to
training hgv drivers not actually
distributing fuel themselves so you know
this is a fast evolving situation i
think really though the government will
be keen to see whether it comes down by
the weekend if as we said earlier
people's uh petrol tanks are full and
there's no sort of pressure there's time
for the fuel companies to
to uh refill their stocks at the petrol
stations then possibly it won't be
needed but you know it's not just
funeral directors there's a whole load
of key workers
some people who you know you know
community nurses um there's uh people
that rely on on you know before you even
get to people that rely on on having
fuel being able to drive around for
their businesses deliveries and so on
there's a whole load of people that are
going to be uh desperately in need
such as ambulance drivers and uh you
know fire
fire emergency vehicles you'd like to
think that they'd be top of the list
anyway um but you know this is this has
happened before in this country heart
back to 2000 i mean i clearly had only
just passed my test then um
but there was obviously there was
obviously a fuel shortage then and and
such measures were deployed as making
sure that key workers were front of the
line and i think if this does go on
beyond the weekend there'll be an
expectation not just from the key
workers themselves but from the public
who rely on them that that happened so i
would expect the government to move on
that quite quickly should we get past
the weekend and the situation not have
improved yeah the telegraph saying that
bin collections are starting to be
cancelled as well um you know
the uk kind of does grind to a halt
doesn't it if you can't get somewhere uh
in the vehicle despite i think it was
the metro front page saying everyone's
going back to public transport um from
my point of view the roads were
certainly quite a lot emptier today than
than they have been in the last week or
so but is there an inevitability um
harry do you think that certain key
workers uh will have to be um
prioritized in this way
if this continues and also i think the
speaking to people in whitehall back in
whitehall today there is an expectation
that this is good they might get through
this week and it might return to normal
this might rear its head again and again
and as you say when people are back on
the trains and things all it takes with
a couple of days of snow thrown into
this one and you've got proper full-on
uh lockdown and chaos i thought point
people made there was really interesting
tonight i have to say with a very senior
former member of the last labour
government who said they still have
chills down their spine when they think
about that fuel crisis in 2002 and it's
it seared the government that that
former government in such a way that
until the into the lead up to the
economic crash it was actually the
biggest sort of biggest jolt they had
and it takes a long time for the public
to
to regain trust that you know such basic
things as being able to go fill up and
drive to do a day's work um
you know it's a basic competence
judgment on on the government so the
while they might get the pumps reopened
in the next 72 hours and things flowing
and they might get through this winter
without more bumps it might take a
little bit longer a very long tail um
for um sort of trust in the government's
competence to recover from this and it's
a little bit unfair you know is it the
government's fault entirely but you know
people make these judgments very quickly
and um if they can't get to work they're
going to be blaming the tories very
quickly yeah
if it continues is the great unknown
isn't it certainly the transport
secretary grant shaps in the statement
from the government tonight about the
army on standby said we are starting to
see panic buying moderate with more
grades of fuel now available at more
petrol stations so that is what they
hope will continue and the question as
to the cause of this issue yes
the hgv the fundamental hgv issue um the
guardian brexit to blame for uk's fuel
crisis as the front runner to succeed
merkel the olaf schultz who is waiting
to see if he can form a coalition
government um this will be subjective
debate and uh no doubt reflection but
there are there are many reasons are
there not why there is an hgv uh
shortage uh pippa don't you
think yes of course it's not just down
to uh the immigration rules that came in
after brexit or
lots of eastern european lorry drivers
deciding they didn't want to come here i
mean another reason is is sort of
comparisons of wages and conditions
between here in the continent and
actually i think it's more lucrative and
the conditions in terms of you know rest
facilities and so on are are better in
the continent than they are here
but it's definitely a factor and it's
actually quite interesting when you sort
of
look at some of the some of the issues
which have been caused in part by brexit
um how
actually
it isn't really being spoken about much
this is a german politician talking
about it we're not hearing the labour
party for example say that brexit's to
blame we're certainly not hearing
members of the government saying that
brexit is uh is a factor in fact they're
denying that it's a factor um there is
still this sort of feeling that
the brexit wars were so divisive and so
difficult that nobody really wants to
quite go back there and revisit them but
it is the case that
brexit was in part a reason for the
situation we're now in and you know i
don't think people should be afraid of
acknowledging that brexit isn't perfect
i don't think even the government would
argue
it's also a process rather than a
destination and this is going to be
inevitable part of the teething process
but i thought what was really
interesting this morning was rachel
reeves on her media round today very
explicitly saying this is the labour's
shadow chancellor very explicitly saying
no we won't be bringing back free
movement no that that argument is done
you know we can look at tinkering around
the edges uh but wholesale free movement
is a is is a done deal and it's not
coming back um but also i think german
newly elected german socialist
politician uh having a pop-up brexit i
don't think it's gonna do
any any standing any bad standing at
home you've gotta look to his audience
he's playing it he's not necessarily
talking to a domestic british audience
with those with those jibes so um good
luck to him yeah that's a win-win for
his own domestic audience is it not as
he tries to form a coalition the
guardian does point out in fact that a
number of eu member states including
germany have a long-standing hgv driver
shortage poland is the worst uh with 124
000 drivers short uk next 60 to 70 60
000 to 76 000 and germany 45 000 to 60
000 but they say unlike the uk companies
in european union member states have
been able to rely on nationals from
their neighbours to fill the gaps that
they say is the difference anyway plenty
more still to come in this part of the
show including the guardian writes about
sabotage claims as labour's andy
mcdonald resigns of course our two
guests tonight from brighton and the
labour party conference will have more
on that in just a moment
[Music]
bob luke got furloughed he was my
husband um
around about the end of last year
october november time and
within that time frame he developed a
gambling disorder
um
i didn't know about any of this until
luke had sadly taken his own life
three weeks later i received his phone
and i was able to log into certain
things and slowly i then started to get
a picture of what had happened and he
had developed that gambling disorder
like i said
um
looking further into his accounts three
bets had been dropping in at times when
he'd put money in and he'd lost it he'd
lost quite a lot of money and then a
free bet went in and then luke would
then
get another loan
put that in lose it
the money had gone another free bet
would go in and it kind of developed and
just progressed basically until he he
lost control and he just couldn't take
it anymore
it was so difficult because that first
three weeks of him passing away um
obviously when someone takes their own
life you do question yourself you think
well you know what did i do the kids
were doing the same thing we've got two
children together um his family we're
all questioning what we've done what
would happen
and it wasn't it was literally when we
got his phone back
the police gave me his phone and i was
able to log into certain accounts his
paypal um the money was going from
paypal into into gambling accounts i
don't look at the money situation to be
fair because um he lost his life it was
a lot of money um it was it was not
affordable and it was why he was he was
funding it with lions because he he
couldn't afford it it wasn't something
he could
use his wages on gambling is a really
harmful product it's addictive it's more
addictive than and class a drugs such as
heroin
and you can lose everything within
minutes um
so yeah the three bets it's an
inducement that is just so unnecessary
um
i feel like
they they just shouldn't be available i
mean luckily i've i've been really
looked after by a charity called
gambling with lives they have been
amazing and they have really taken care
of me every day is hard and
every day i'm going to have to live with
the fact that he's no longer here
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms
human beings directly depend on
underground water source so a lake or a
pond is necessary to replenish these
groundwater resources
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview i'm joined now from the
labour party conference in brighton by
pippa crera and harry cole from the
mirror and son respectively welcome back
to both of you and so the guardian talks
about the big news from their pippa
the resignation of a front bencher
and suggesting it might have been
sabotage in its uh in its article tell
us more
well the last the first couple of days
of labour conference have got off to a
bit of a bumpy start we had angel arena
of course talking about
describing tory cabinet ministers as
scum and then we had the the almighty
rio over rule changes for the labour
party um which were eventually won by
kyo stammer and just as they thought
that everything was going to calm down a
bit andy mcdonald who's this fairly
junior cabin minister the only remaining
carbonite left in the shadow cabinet
quits ostensibly over a minimum wage
route but i think we all know that it
wasn't really much to do with that it
was that he didn't feel comfortable uh
as being the only sort of standard
bearer of the left left and shadow
cabinet had concerns about the rule
change and when you look at people that
have applauded his departure tonight
like john mcdonnell and trace union
leaders next union leaders you see that
he really is above a bit of the party
that's no longer represented amongst the
leadership and probably just wanted out
yes on the front page though we saw
rachel reeves it was her big day wasn't
it um today harry what did you pick up
from that and has this overshadowed what
she had to say
no not really i think i won't be telling
secrets out of school too much to to to
say when the wire snapped andy mcdonald
has resigned um there was a sort of a
whisper a murmur of who um around the
press room uh here here in brighton but
look i mean
i think you know deep down big picture
if you if you asked kierstarma you know
whether he'd have got his uh got his
leadership changes through that he was
desperate to do last year but couldn't
because there wasn't a conference and
doesn't want to be doing next year
because it would be an election cycle by
then whether he got those through
whether
jeremy corbyn is a sort of almost a
fringe figure here sort of on the
outskirts of the conference not drawing
anywhere near the crowds
uh he has drawn previously at these
affairs
uh and uh a relatively unknown if a
little grumpy back but um shadow cabinet
member retiring to the back benches um
you can see why some of the people
around here and his supporters kind of
soon as a network